bonsoir et bienvenue dans savouregarde
ravi de vous retrouver notre grand
témoin ce soir veut ton finir avec la
tyrannie du divertissement c'est le
titre de votre livre Olivier Babeau
bonsoir merci d'être là président de
l'Institut sapiens le temps libre est
une affaire très sérieuse nous dites
vous devez aujourd'hui par les écrans
qui ont pris le pouvoir sur nos vies on
va en parler comment s'en dépendre
est-ce que le goût de l'effort est aussi
une affaire politique vous ne le direz
dans la deuxième partie mais on commence
ce soir par ces deux mots industrie
vertes de mots qui semblent dissonant à
l'oreille et qui pourtant représente
notre avenir la désindustrialisation
pardon la réindustrialisation de la
France ne se fera que si elle est
décarbonée mais notre pays s'en
donne-t-il vraiment les moyens un projet
de loi et débattu en commission à
l'Assemblée on en parle dans un instant
avec nos invités avant de retrouver nos
parties pris nos affranchis bien sûr et
puis Bourbon Express l'histoire du jour
à l'Assemblée voilà pour le menu ce soir
vous êtes prêts on y va Olivier Babeau
ça vous regarde c'est parti
[Musique]
c'est sans doute l'un des enjeux de
souveraineté les plus importants pour le
pays la réindustrialisation à condition
qu'elle soit décarbonée alors au-delà
des grands discours que fait précisément
le gouvernement pour accompagner surtout
aider financièrement les entreprises à
investir le projet de loi sur les
industries vertes affichent des
ambitieuses objectifs il est temps
commission à l'Assemblée mais se
donne-t-il les moyens de les atteindre
alors qui de mieux ce soir que le
ministre de l'industrie pourrait
répondre à ces questions bonsoir Roland
Lescure merci beaucoup d'avoir accepté
notre invitation vous êtes celui qui
pilote à Bercy avec Bruno Le Maire cette
politique de réindustrialisation verte
on va en parler dans le détail vous
débattez ce soir avec Sandrine Rousseau
bonsoir bonsoir merci d'être là
députérops écologie aller vers de Paris
votre partie n'est pas hostile par
principe à cette idée de l'industrie
verte mais il a voté contre le projet de
loi au Sénat vous nous direz pourquoi
enfin bonsoir Vincent Charlet bienvenue
vous êtes délégué général de la fabrique
de l'industrie d'un laboratoire d'idées
un signe tank en bon français présidé
par Louis Gallois aussi un patron PSA et
de la SNCF Olivier babot vous êtes un
économiste la politique industrielle
vous connaissez vous nous direz ce que
vous pensez de celle du gouvernement on
commence par planter le décor avec
Stéphane blackovski quels sont nos
atouts en la matière et que prévoient ce
projet de loi le chrono de la peau pour
commencer
et je me retourne comme chaque soir pour
vous accueillir mon cher Stéphane
bonsoir à vous je vous souhaite toutes
et tous alors ce projet de loi alors ce
soir on parle d'un objectif que Bruno Le
Maire s'est fixé au tout début du mois
de janvier vous savez la période où on
prend des bonnes résolutions pour
l'avenir et ça bonne résolution un autre
ministre de l'Économie regardez c'est
donc de faire de la France la Première
nation de l'industrie verte en Europe
alors évidemment viser la première place
en Europe en tout cas c'est très
français on n'est pas loin du petit
cocorico qu'on pourrait pousser mais
quand même ce concept d'industrie verte
qui interroge parce que par exemple
Michel et ma belle sont deux mots qui
vont très bien ensemble ça on est on est
d'accord en revanche industrie verte ça
fait aussi mort ça fait deux termes
totalement
contradictoires parce qu'a priori si on
veut protéger l'environnement est-ce que
spontanément on se dit rien
industrialisons dans ce cas la France
construisant des
usines partout est-ce que c'est ça
vraiment être vert et bien oui c'est ce
que pense Bruno Le Maire il s'explique
je ne crois absolument pas cette
solution de facilité qui consisterait à
dire on va fermer les usines et comme ça
on émettra moins de CO2 donc en
renonçant à notre production nationale
nous importons des biens qui sont plus
émetteurs de CO2 pour moi c'est la
fausse route totale celle que nous avons
ici d'inverser avec le président de la
République alors ce projet de loi
industrielle repose en gros on va dire
sur deux piliers le premier poli c'est
déjà la décarbonation des industries
existantes le gouvernement notamment
identifié les 56 qui sont les plus gros
voleurs en France et met de l'argent sur
la table une dizaine de milliards pour
réduire d'ici 2030 de 45% les émissions
de ces sites qui construisent beaucoup à
la contribue pardon beaucoup à la
pollution via l'autre pilier dont on
parlait c'est-à-dire l'idée de
construire de nouvelles usines mais
évidemment des
usines où on fabriquerait des produits
utiles pour lutter contre le
réchauffement gouvernement d'ailleurs
fait une liste sans surprise hein ce
sont les pompes à chaleur les panneaux
photovoltaïques les éoliennes
l'hydrogène et les batteries d'ailleurs
quand on parle de batterie j'imagine que
vous vous souvenez puisque quand même il
y avait toute une communication autour
de ça de la visite à Dunkerque du
président Macron pour annoncer
l'implantation d'une usine d'une giga
usine de batterie avec des investisseurs
taïwanais pour contribuer à ça donc
évidemment le déroulement aimerait bien
multiplier les projets de ce genre là
donc il y a deux règles qui cherchent à
imposer c'est d'une part rendre des
terrains disponibles immédiatement pour
ceux qui voudraient investir donc
réhabiliter des friches et puis
accélérer donc réduire les délais
d'autorisation administrative pour
installer les nouvelles usines en les
faisant passer de 17 à 9 mois donc
évidemment si on se dit que produire des
batteries pour des voitures électriques
ça réduit les émissions de CO2 ça existe
donc ce concept d'industrie verte sauf
que ah je vois que Sandrine Rousseau
croise les bras parce que les Verts ne
sont pas d'accord ils trouvent pas ça
très bien il y a une tribune qui a été
publiée donc c'est une centaine d'élus
avec legistes qu'ils l'ont signé en
disant que cette loi industrielle n'a de
vertes que le nom d'ailleurs vous allez
entendre marine pondelier qui est la
patronne de les Verts et vous allez voir
qu'elle ne partage pas du tout
l'enthousiasme du président à propos de
la gigafactory de Dunkerque qu'on écoute
ça me donne envie de pleurer en fait et
de voir Macron se pavaner pour dire moi
je fais 20 000 emplois de batterie de
giga Factory ok mais sur des terres qui
en plus si ça tombe dans 20 ans se rend
sous la flotte parce que Dunkerque c'est
quand même des polaires et regarder le
trait de code dans les années qui
viennent sur des terres en plus
agricoles bon je crois que là ça fait
pas de doute on a compris que les Verts
votre rencontre ce projet-là mais
attention parce que au Sénat les
écologistes ont été les seuls à voter
contre puisque la gauche elle a préféré
s'abstenir à l'Assemblée bah voilà les
débats ont commencé en commission mais
rien n'empêche de les poursuivre ce soir
en studio merci beaucoup Stéphane on va
commencer par quelques questions très
simples le projet de loi ne définit pas
véritablement ce que c'est qu'une
industrie verte de façon très claire et
crie qu'est-ce que c'est Monsieur le
Ministre parce que ça a été bien dit par
votre chroniqueur Stéphane c'est à dire
que c'est à la fois la décarbonation de
l'industrie traditionnelle et ça je
dirais ça concerne tout le monde ça fait
150 ans qu'on fait de l'acier à partir
du charbon aujourd'hui on peut faire de
l'acier à partir de l'hydrogène mais
pour ça on va en parler parce qu'on est
allé à Dunkerque justement chez
arteelormittal mais je vous laisse tout
de suite donc on décarbonne les aciéries
les cimenteries les hallumineries et on
a parlé des 56 à E50 qui représentent
60% des émissions industrielles donc si
vous décarbonez ces 56 - 50 % d'ici 2030
et - 100 % des d'ici 2050 nous a fait 62
les industriels de la chimie de la
médaillerie de la sidérurgie et puis
vous mettez les autres il y a deux
enjeux il y a deux piliers de la
réindustrialisation verte c'est
décarboner l'industrie traditionnelle
sinon Bruno Le Maire l'a dit elle ira
ailleurs et profiter
et construire l'industrie de la
décarbonation donc par exemple pour des
carboner l'acier il faut de l'hydrogène
l'industrie de l'hydrogène c'est une
nouvelle industrie qui va créer de
l'emploi qui va permettre de décarboner
l'industrie traditionnelle donc pour
simplifier on réconcilie économie
écologie en tout cas nous on pense que
c'est la bonne manière pour le faire
alors on sait que on revient de très
très loin en matière industrielle il y a
eu 2 millions et demi d'emplois
industriels qui ont été détruits la part
de l'industrie c'est 11% de la richesse
nationale aujourd'hui c'était il faut
s'en rappeler plus du double il y a 50
ans Bruno Le Maire il s'est engagé à
monter cette part à 15 % d'ici 2030
est-ce qu'il veut il parvenir uniquement
je dis bien uniquement avec de
l'industrie verte c'est à dire qu'on ne
fera plus de nouvelles usines en France
si elles n'ont pas ces objectifs là
alors on les fera avec de l'industrie en
tout cas décarbonée mais ce sera pas
juste des poteaux des panneaux
photovoltaïques typiquement moi je
souhaite qu'on assemble des véhicules
électriques en France donc ça c'est des
usines je dirais traditionnelles qui ont
un contenu carboné beaucoup moins
important dans le passé mais il y a
quand même de l'acier des pneus on les
assemble on consomme de l'énergie elle
aussi on souhaite qu'elle soit
décarbonée mais si vous construisez des
véhicules en France
ils sont en plus électriques plutôt que
de les importer de Chine au total vous
décarbonez la planète donc même si vous
comprenez
là je pense qu'on sera d'accord c'est un
enjeu politique culturel et sociétal
important les citoyens souhaitent qu'on
fasse 2 ce qui a changé depuis un an
c'est que les chefs d'entreprise
souhaitent le faire en partie parce que
s'ils veulent recruter ils ont besoin
d'expliquer à leur futur ingénieurs
techniciens y compris ouvriers qui sont
intéressés par ça
pas tous mais il y a quand même de plus
en plus des actionnaires qui souhaitent
le faire donc je pense qu'on a vraiment
un changement de culture qui est en
train de se faire donc ça veut pas dire
que tout sera décarboné du jour au
lendemain mais que vous ne pouvez plus
aujourd'hui produire davantage sans
expliquer comment vous allez décarboner
à vos actionnaires au grand public à vos
futurs salariés et aux politiques parce
qu'évidemment nous on a pris des
engagements par exemple de sortir du
véhicule thermique en 2035 en Europe
évidemment si demain quelqu'un venait
venu nous voir en disant je vais créer
une usine diesel on disait bah non c'est
pas possible aujourd'hui je vais faire
circuler la parole mais je voudrais
juste encore une dernière question va
revenir sur les enjeux de financement
parce que c'est très très important les
États-Unis mettent un paquet de
milliards sur la table les Chinois aussi
j'ai lu dans le projet de loi que il y a
23 milliards d'euros d'investissement
d'ici 2030 sur les industries vertes
avec un objectif de réduire de 41
millions de tonnes de CO2 cette
industrie là d'ici 2030 et c'est 40
000 emplois directs créés cet argent des
23 milliards on y reviendra mais qui
paye d'où il vient en partie les
industriels on va pas leur faire un
chèque en blanc mais en partie en
subvention liée à France 2030 donc le
président de la République a annoncé par
exemple ou 56 il les a reçu à l'Élysée
en avant dernier il vous travaillez avec
le ministre de l'Industrie vous me
faites des programmes de décarbonation
si vous êtes capable d'aller plus vite à
l'époque à l'époque pardon il devait
faire 25% de réduction en 2030
maintenant ils sont prêts à s'engager à
50% , moi je serais prêt à mettre 10
milliards sur la table donc il y a une
partie d'argent public qui vient
à peu près je dirais deux tiers d'argent
privé qui va falloir aller trouver quand
même c'est pas gagné on va en reparler
Sandrine Rousseau
faciliter favoriser les industries
vertes la croissance verte c'est pas ce
que vous souhaitez
on est toujours dans cette idée que une
croissance infinie dans un monde fini et
possible on est toujours dans l'idée que
on va garder les voitures mais on va en
changer le moteur et puis tout va bien
aller moi j'ai l'impression et alors
quand vous parliez d'objectif en fait
sur tout cette loi n'a pas d'objectif
enfin vraiment pour le coup il y a aucun
objectif un temps soit peu imposé aux
industriels on est dans une espèce
d'incantation aux objectifs exactement
de la même manière que quand on a créé
je sais pas si vous vous souvenez le
cice ou le pack de responsabilité à
l'époque le Medef avait un pin's avec
marqué un million d'emplois bon à la fin
il y en a il y en a des crédits
qui a été créé grâce au cice mais il y
avait quand même le pin's bah là c'est
pareil si en fait on a le titre de la
loi donc c'est industrie verte comme on
avait la loi pouvoir d'achat et en fait
à la fin ce sont des c'est le texte
n'est en rien contraignant en rien
contraignant il y a pas de financement
ça vient d'être noir c'est surtout il y
a rien sur la propriétés il y a rien sur
les sur l'économie circulaire ou par un
article qui a été ajouté au Sénat par
les écologistes enfin qui probablement
dans la CMP va être contredit par
ailleurs et c'est vraiment quelque chose
qui est toujours dans ce même logiciel
que j'appelle le logiciel des 30
glorieuses dont on doit absolument
sortir aujourd'hui pour aller vers une
autre réflexion qui est une réflexion
des besoins essentiels de quoi
avons-nous absolument besoin et pas du
tout jour plus mais de d'une
transformation par exemple aujourd'hui
et ça a été dit par la Cour des comptes
cette semaine on a absolument besoin
d'investissement majeur dans les
transports en commun là par exemple rien
n'est fait spécifiquement sur ce
domaine-là c'est-à-dire que si une
entreprise veut bénéficier de ça pour
éventuellement faire des transports en
commun très bien mais il y a pas de
d'encadrement
mais de stratégie de l'État pour
transformer en profondeur notre économie
alors il y a deux il y a deux choses
nous manque aujourd'hui il y a la
question de la contrainte et ensuite la
question de recyclage et de l'économie
circulaire madame Rousseau dit il y a
rien en texte à part un article il y
avait l'article 4 qui était dans le
projet de loi qui a été voté c'est le
seul à l'unanimité en commission y
compris par les membres de votre groupe
c'est-à-dire que l'article
en fait l'article 4 c'est de l'économie
circulaire qu'est-ce qu'il dit c'est que
Arcelor Arcelor si il utilise des
déchets donc de l'acier
en rebut dans son processus de
production ça va être plus simple pour
lui de sortir de ce qu'on appelle du
statut de déchet aujourd'hui vous voulez
utiliser une bouteille en plastique vous
voulez la recycler pour faire du tableau
de bord d'un véhicule ça existe ça ça
prend un an si vous voulez utiliser un
t-shirt et le recycler en chiffon ça
prend un an de procédure donc on a voté
à l'unanimité un article qui fait qu'on
va être davantage incité mais c'est vrai
que c'est de l'incitation à recycler des
matériaux de base pour décarboner
l'industrie et ça tout le monde est
d'accord
s
tout à l'heure ils font des crédits
d'impôts nous on en fait pas Bruxelles
était contre massif donc nous ils seront
pas massifs mais ils seront importants
en revanche on s'est engagé à ce que ces
crédits d'impôts verts donc une
considère que les industries vertes
panneaux solaires et aux liens vous
l'avez dit batterie hydrogène et pompe à
chaleur c'est tout pour les usines qui
vont fabriquer ça en France il y aura
des crédits d'impôts en revanche on
s'est engagé à financer ça par la fin de
brune c'est-à-dire des niches fiscales
aujourd'hui qui encourage la carbonation
donc c'est pour ça qu'on a mis tout ça
en projet de loi de finance de manière à
ce qu'on puisse discuter je dirais
l'ensemble de l'homme mais l'ensemble
engagé
si je puis dire à mettre en place ces
crédits d'impôts mais en revanche tout
ça doit discuter avec donc ça circule la
parole rapidement
une toute puce à côté d'harcelormittal
il y avait un pôle industriel qui
essayait d'utiliser comme ça les déchets
de manière circulaire sur un pôle
industriel ou les entreprises se
racheter mutuellement leurs déchets pour
faire en sorte que ce soit des matières
premières pour les entreprises suivantes
il se trouve que ça moi je l'ai étudié
quand j'étais tes arbres je vais vous
dire s'il y a 20 il y a combien il y a
30 ans maintenant et on en est toujours
là c'est-à-dire qu'en fait il y a
aujourd'hui la nécessité c'est de moins
utiliser de matériaux de ne plus aller
ponctionner les ressources de faire en
sorte que ça ne soit pas juste des
déchets qui soient transformés mais
qu'il y ait moins de qu'il y ait moins
de de d'extractivisme et d'extraction
donc ça passe par de la sobriété voir de
la génoise il y a rien là-dessus il y a
rien dessus et ça c'est un danger alors
en fait pour reculer la parole Vincent
Charlet il y a des objectifs de
réduction d'émissions de 45% sur 56 qui
ont été
identifiés par le gouvernement Stéphane
blackovski en parlait on peut d'ailleurs
voir la carte c'est toute la France il y
a beaucoup de d'usines dans la vallée du
Rhône dans le nord et à l'est également
il y a 10 milliards sur la table pour
réussir à faire on voit la carte 45% de
réduction d'émissions
ces missions possibles ou pas selon vous
alors formuler comme ça oui mais pour
revenir sur ce qui va nous dire je crois
pas que ce soit un objet de débat on
sait qu'il y a urgence on sait qu'il va
falloir cumuler les efforts les
individus vont devoir changer de mode de
transport arrêtez de prendre l'avion moi
manger de viande arrêter de se chauffer
au gaz les industriels vont devoir faire
des efforts et on va falloir isoler
bâtiments donc et on sait que même si on
accumule tout ça on sera encore pas
exactement sur la question d'y parvenir
on est plus sur les objectifs industrie
et pour l'instant la partie du système
qui est le plus dans la trajectoire à
2030 à 2050 c'est l'inconnu en fait
personne ne sait dire ni combien ça
coûtera ni si on va y arriver à 2030
pour l'instant l'industrie est sur la
trajectoire la France dans son ensemble
avec les particuliers logements non donc
il y a du boulot et pour répondre à
votre question oui ces missions
possibles mais ça réclame un mur
d'investissement un effort
d'investissement que jamais ces
industries n'ont connu c'est la question
à l'économiste que vous êtes Olivier
bimbaud puis ensuite on verra le
reportage à Dunkerque sur Arcelor un mur
d'investissement on a tous en tête le
rapport de Champigny ferry 66 milliards
pour des carbonées d'ici 2050 je sais
pas si c'est à peu près 20-25 milliards
pour pour la part ou peut-être plus de
l'industrie quand on voit ce que font
les Américains est-ce que nous européens
il faut remettre un peu les échelles on
est on est en capacité
d'arriver à ces objectifs
on va bien il va bien falloir il va
peut-être une première remarque à faire
c'est que la réindustrialisation elle
est pas seulement intéressante
nationalement et surtout intéressante
pour lutter contre les inégalités
territoriales et qui sont très fortes en
France parce que les industries sont
rarement dans les grandes villes et
c'est leur chance il y a deux problèmes
essentiels il y a le syndrome Nimbi not
in my bakkyard c'est-à-dire pas chez moi
je veux bien des industries je veux bien
des trucs mais surtout pas chez moi donc
ça il faut arriver encourager les
territoires à la plantation et le
deuxième c'est le problème de
concurrence équitable avec des étrangers
des industries étrangères qui ne
respectent pas les mêmes normes et qui
elle du coup peuvent importer avec des
prix qui sont inférieurs c'est là qu'il
y a une forme de tarification du carbone
à avoir pour que les industries qui font
cet effort et qui font ces
investissements puissent être joué à
armes égales évidemment avec les
industries étrangers
voilà c'est beaucoup plus compliqué
qu'on ne le pense alors simplement en
fait il y a un premier effet qui se
coule si vous voulez c'est qu'en fait
vous commencez par acheter beaucoup plus
cher les ce que vous allez utiliser pour
produire donc déjà c'est un effet assez
impressionniste sur votre coup de
production au tout début et puis après
bon c'est pas si simple à tarifier en
fait le carbone et accompagné
une fois qu'ils sont transportés
pour terminer juste sur l'investissement
il y a un mur d'investissement et je
ferai marqué malheureusement c'est pas
le seul parce qu'il y a la défense par
exemple ça en fait beaucoup et puis il y
a demain il y a la dépendance qui fait
que ça en fait beaucoup comment on va
financer tout ça sans toucher la dette
sans toucher les riches grande question
mais on le garde pour tout à l'heure on
part à Dunkerque pour regarder très
concrètement sur le terrain comment ce
travail de décarbonation s'opère c'est
Clément pervaud qui s'est rendu sur le
site industriel d'Arcelor Mittal gros
poids lourd de l'industrie en France
regardez reportage
le grand port industriel de Dunkerque
est l'un des sites les plus polluants
d'Europe à lui seul il est responsable
de 20% des émissions industrielles de
CO2 de la France mais un changement de
cas radical est amorcé ici place
désormais à l'industrie verte la zone
industrielle de Dunkerque veut réduire
de 30% ses émissions de CO2 en 2030 puis
atteindre la neutralité carbone en 2050
première priorité verdir l'industrie
existante voici ArcelorMittal poids
lourd de la sidérurgie française sur
l'immensite Dunkerquois long de 7 km les
grandes manœuvres ont commencé et la
première étape c'est d'augmenter la
recyclabilité de l'acier et ici vous
avez l'illustration très concrète
comment on traite l'acier recyclé quand
il arrive sur l'usine donc il arrive
dans des camions en troubles d'accord il
est trié d'accord c'est pour ça que vous
voyez que on fait différents tas qui
sont pas tous les on sélectionne un peu
les différents aciers et ça va terminer
à la scierie qui est le bâtiment qui est
derrière nous là-bas au fond c'est ce
qui nous permet de gagner déjà 15% de
réduction de gaz à effet de serre le
recyclage est sans doute la partie la
plus simple du processus de
décarbonation un autre grand chantier
sera de remplacer progressivement l'un
des au fourneaux du site par défaut à
hydrogène mais même si la part peut-être
réduite il reste technologiquement
impossible de produire de l'acier sans
émettre de CO2 seule solution pour
atteindre la neutralité carbone parvenir
à le capter sur le site d'Arcelor un
projet européen commence à y travailler
dans ce gros tuyau gris surtout le gaz
de haut fourneau donc ces gaz de
fourneau c'est un mélange d'azote
d'ouceo et de dioxyde de carbone et nous
allons récupérer dans le tuyau jaune une
toute petite fraction et va être
acheminée jusqu'à ses colonnes ici qu'on
appelle l'absorbeur on va mettre en
contact le gaz avec un liquide et dû à
la forte affinité entre le liquide et le
gaz il va jusqu'à capter le CO2 la
structure installée sur le site n'est
encore qu'un démonstrateur pour
expérimenter la technologie
[Musique]
au-delà des sites déjà implantés
l'industrie verte à Dunkerque se sont
aussi de nouvelles usines qui vont
sortir de terre plus vertueuses
écologiquement la première sera celle du
français Vercors qui ambitionne de
produire 700 000 batteries par an pour
le modèle alpine de la marque Renault le
taïwanais prologium prévoit lui aussi
d'installer une gigafactory de batterie
pour automobile ces deux projets
représenteront à eux seuls près de 8
milliards d'investissements et 8000
emplois
voilà on retrouve les milliards
d'investissement Roland Lescure sur
Arcelor c'est intéressant parce que il y
avait trois au fourneaux ils en ont
fermé il y en a plus que deux on
comprend qu'il y en a un qui va se
convertir à l'hydrogène mais pour ça il
faut beaucoup beaucoup d'électricité ça
veut dire quoi il y a une usine
nucléaire à côté il y a des parcs
offshore est-ce que tout ça va réussir à
se coordonner et à trouver les moyens
financiers pour pour arriver à temps
face à l'urgence climatique et c'est
tout le temps ce qu'on appelle la
planification écologique donc le
président a convoqué un conseil de la
planification écologique l'odyssée du S
c'est exactement ça l'objectif quand on
ajoute les objectifs du ministre de
l'Industrie ceux du ministre des
Transports ceux de la ministre de
l'énergie se limite de l'agriculture
puisse du logement c'est en gros ça les
cinq gros émetteurs est-ce que ça boucle
on va avoir besoin de beaucoup
d'électricité décarbonée donc le choix
c'est pas est-ce qu'il faut de du
nucléaire ou est-ce qu'il faut des des
renouvelables il faut les deux et
beaucoup il y en a un qui prend plus de
temps le nucléaire il y en a un qui va
j'espère un peu plus vite grâce à une
loi votée récemment donc on va faire les
deux et est-ce qu'on a suffisamment
d'argent donc c'est intéressant Arcelor
parce que sur babo disait tout à l'heure
on est dans une concurrence
internationale y compris au sein
d'Arcelor les Arcelor c'est un groupe
mondial aujourd'hui donc il va décider
d'investir
soit en France soit aux États-Unis soit
en Allemagne soit en Inde et je peux
dire les trois personnes qu'on a vu là
c'est des personnes exceptionnelles
parce qu'ils sont extrêmement mobilisés
ils doivent convaincre leur actionnaire
de le faire en France c'est là
qu'evidemment l'État aux États-Unis ou
beaucoup des subventions publiques de
l'Irak c'est une histoire de priorité et
je peux vous dire quand on parle au
grand groupe internationaux et qu'on
compare l'IRA et ce qu'on fait en France
France 2030 les montants vous disiez
tout à l'heure à porter aux produits
interdits sont pas très différents ce
qui est très fort aux États-Unis c'est
la rapidité l'efficacité des procédures
moi j'ai rencontré le gouverneur du
Texas va installer une usine au Texas ça
prend en terme d'autorisation trois mois
chez nous ça prend 18 mois et après le
projet de loi on est en train d'examiner
ça en prendra 9 comme en Allemagne ça
c'est un enjeu très important très
pratique présent dans le projet de loi
alors Vincent Charlet la question c'est
aussi où où on va les mettre ces
nouvelles usines c'est la question des
friches ind matériel on lit qu'on a des
milliers d'hectares de disponibles
comment ça se passe concrètement il faut
dépolluer les sites avant de pouvoir les
exploiter où il y a déjà des sites parce
qu'il y a aussi des contraintes
climatiques
il y a plus que la première pelleté à
mettre pour construire l'usine comment
ça se passe il peut y avoir des sites
globalement on a aujourd'hui un problème
d'accès aux fonciers mais qui se pose à
l'industrie comme il se posent à tout le
monde la première source de pression sur
le foncier c'est le logement résidentiel
l'industrie fait face à la même pénurie
mais elle n'en est pas responsable et
donc la situation était hétérogène en
fait dans la vallée du Rhône c'est
saturé de chez saturé donc il est
extrêmement difficile de d'avoir accès à
quelques hectares ou mètres carrés dans
les hauts de France c'est peut-être pas
un hasard il y a plus de marge de
manœuvre et donc plus plus de souplesse
industriel une réhabiliter clé en main
c'est ça l'objectif 2027 2000 hectares
2027 avec un objectif climatique quand
même lasagne le fameux zéro
artificialisation nette on s'assoit
dessus manifestement Sandrine Rousseau
j'ai bien compris que c'est non
du Zéro artificielisme justement de ne
pas artificialiser
le nord et le Pas-de-Calais sont les
deux départements de France où il y a le
moins d'hectares de forêts d'espaces
naturels
particulièrement le Nord et en fait là
ce qu'on fait c'est que on fait des
exceptions au droit de l'environnement
pourquoi c'est long en France parce que
précisément il y a du un droit de
l'environnement il y a un droit qui
d'ailleurs est assez peu ambitieux en
réalité à la fin de préservation des de
la biodiversité ça pourrait être bien
au-delà de ce que c'est de préservation
des terres agricoles etc et là on
s'aperçoit qu'il y a des dans le projet
de loi des facilitations pour si vous
détruisez des espèces à un endroit pour
voir les réimplanter un autre et en fait
on est la biodiversité mais on est on
est dans un anéantissement de la
biodiversité c'est en cela que je vous
disais que ce projet est à mon avis daté
et qu'on aurait pu le produire de la
même manière en 1970 ou 80 parce qu'en
fait si on regarde quand le
développement durable est sorti quand la
notion de développement durable est
sortie en cas du rapport brunchland et
bien on avait exactement les mêmes
discours politique sauf que on est 20 ou
30 ans après et que là on a plus que
deux ou trois ans pour changer
radicalement nos modes de consommation
et de production je rappelle quand même
qu'en France on a une empreinte
écologique de 11 tonnes de carbone par
habitant et qu'il nous faut tomber à
deux qu'il nous faut tomber à deux d'ici
2050 ce qui est un changement mais d'une
radicalité que l'on imagine encore
aujourd'hui malheureusement pas et en
fait si quand on fait des giga Factory
de batterie on fait quoi on remplace une
voiture thermique par une voiture
électrique alors que il nous manque
comme maillon de réflexion ce qui ce
dont on a absolument avons besoin en
termes d'industrie pour changer de
système économique pas juste pour avoir
de nouveaux besoins
précisément par exemple on aurait pu
avoir un plan de développement très
majeur des transports en commun des
infrastructures de la rénovation
thermique ce qui aujourd'hui n'est pas
le cas on se rappelle que dans le cadre
du vote du budget les crédits qui ont
été alloués à ça ont été supprimés dans
le cadre du 49-3 donc en fait on a
l'impression de quelque chose qui prend
les habits de l'écologie mais qui au
final est toujours un projet de
productivisme de croissance mais qui n'a
de verre que de techno solutionnisme
certains
illustrer le débat avec un sujet que
Madame au se connaît bien c'est celui de
l'aéronautique on a vraiment deux choix
donc aujourd'hui la France produit la
moitié des avions mondiaux la moitié et
les avions mondiaux c'est 3% des
émissions mondiales donc si on
décarbonne l'aviation française si on
invente l'avion propre vous avez eu ça
peut-être de la technoolutionnisme mais
juste l'avion faible consommation donc
si on est capable investir aux côtés des
industriels pour décarboner l'aviation
on a les moyens de décarboner la moitié
de la version mondiale donc de supprimer
1,5 des émissions de gaz à effet de
serre mondial ça c'est un beau projet
avec à la clé aujourd'hui plus de 300
000 emplois ça c'est vrai que c'est
l'option que nous en privilégié et enfin
je vous laisserai la préciser mais
l'option que vous privilégiez plutôt
c'est il faut arrêter de prendre l'avion
plus ou moins qu'avant
c'est exactement cette société
on l'a fait pendant trois jours
franchement là Monsieur Fournier madame
châtelain était là ils ont pas voté la
loi on a eu plein de débats super
intéressants qui permettent d'éclairer
ses choix de société sur
la caisse climatique du zéro
officialisation d'être c'est vrai
qu'elle est friche donc ça c'est déjà là
il faut les réhabiliter pour pouvoir
faire les usines mais il y a cet
objectif qui était voté par la loi
Macron aux lois climat et résilience on
en fait quoi ne le maire veut sortir les
industries vertes c'est réglé puisque la
Commission mixparitaire sur la PPL Zaz
donc avec du Sénat a été conclusive hier
c'est bien tombé parce qu'on était en
pleine examen de notre loi à l'Assemblée
donc ça nous a permis d'oublier l'espace
d'un instant ce sujet qui est un sujet
compliqué mais
une usine si elle fabrique par exemple
des panneaux solaires sur une terre qui
alors que ce soit
commercial ou une autoroute on diminue
ça a été voté effectivement par la loi
climat résilience l'artificialisation
donc c'est plus compliqué on peut pas
juste faire des usines donc quand vous
créez une usine sur une nouvelle zone
alors la conclusion hier de la CMP c'est
que globalement sur les 120
000 hectares d'artificialisation qui
vont venir sur lequel il y aura des
autorisations express et en gros des
quotas il y en a 10 000 qui sont exclus
sur lesquels il y aura pas de quota et
qui permettront à la fois de créer des
logements vous demander au maire de
Dunkerque aujourd'hui son problème c'est
les logements c'est pas les usines donc
des logements des industries des
autoroutes donc c'est une exception de
10% qui va permettre d'aller un peu plus
vite mais globalement l'objectif de non
artificialisation net des sols il est
respecté en tout cas ce que je peux vous
dire c'est que la majorité va voter en
tout cas c'est conclusions je pense la
semaine prochaine je voudrais qu'on
éclaircisse et on termine ce débat sur
le financement est-ce que vous vous avez
compris un peu le fléchage de l'argent
on a l'impression Vincent Charlet ça va
être l'épargne qui va être sollicité des
Français on va pas creuser la dette ça
semble impossible face aux murs
d'investissement nécessaire alors je
pense que de toute façon il faudra
l'argent de tout le monde oui
mobiliser l'épargne c'est c'est comme
d'autres sujets ça fait très longtemps
ou quand on a commencé nos études qu'on
en parlait déjà on sait que l'épargne
elle est plutôt dormante et un peu
inefficace alors selon les urgences du
moment on
que ces 370 milliards de dollars Lyra
américain pour se donner un peu des
échelles oublions un peu lira alors je
sais que mes interrupteurs n'aiment pas
quand je dis ça mais
si je vous donne une baguette magique à
un coup et que je vous laisse le choix
entre diminuer la facture énergétique de
l'industrie française ou supprimer faire
disparaître l'IRA ne vous trompez pas si
vous faites disparaître vous ne résolvez
aucun problème de l'industrie française
européenne si vous redescendez au niveau
pré 2019 la prévisibilité et les prix
l'énergie aujourd'hui en France et en
Europe l'Iran n'est pas un problème un
problème pour personne la volonté
politique européenne d'investir ingrat
qui nous renvoie à nos difficultés et à
nos défauts mais ça n'est pas un
problème pour industrie européenne
aujourd'hui sauf quelques sites très
localisés qui évidemment pour des
calculs économiques seront peut-être
forcés de se délocaliser mais c'est bien
le prix l'énergie ou le prix ou la le
risque
et l'incertitude autour des prix
d'énergie aujourd'hui dans deux ans qui
font que lira devient une tentation
Sandrine Rousseau on a compris que les
grosses
usines les grosses industries vont
mettre la main porte-monnaie mais il y
aura aussi de l'argent public vous vous
préconisez quel type de financement non
mais là il faut de l'investissement
direct avec une conditionnalité de
chaque euro qui était qui est investi
qui est ce que le gouvernement ce à quoi
le gouvernement s'est refusé de manière
systématique dans tous les dans toutes
les études si c'est de l'argent public
on creuse la dette
vert comme le souhaite j'en puisse Annie
ferry non mais je rappelle quand même
que les l'imposition sur les plus riches
et plus faibles aujourd'hui que
l'imposition sur les classes moyenne
donc en fait c'est pas possible donc il
y a quand même une forme de justice
fiscale à retrouver et de retrouver le
sens de la subvention comme étant une
arme en fait de
stratégie et je j'aurais peut-être ce
mot pour dire quand même que ce projet
de loi est à quelque chose d'imodeste
c'est à dire que on a l'impression qu'on
va changer le monde et surtout
d'inefficace et on le voit parce qu'en
fait l'argent n'est pas là il y a pas
d'objectif il y a pas de contraintes
dans
le dernier budget il y a ils ont refusé
le gouvernement a refuser
systématiquement toute conditionnalités
des aides publiques alors qu'aujourd'hui
tout euros de public devrait être
regardé et d'ailleurs la Cour des
comptes le dit mais peu la Cour des
comptes imaginons que ce soit même pas
la Cour des comptes mais tout au public
aujourd'hui compte tenu de l'urgence
dans laquelle nous sommes devrait être
regardés à l'aune de ses conséquences
sur l'environnement et quand je disais
que tout à l'heure on avait deux projets
de société je pense que le projet de
société que vous défendez est un projet
où on croit à une forme de Père Noël
industrielle et surtout on ne regarde
pas avec lucidité le mur climatique qui
arrive et je vous laisse le mot de la
fin sur le financement c'est ça qui nous
intéresse parce que votre projet
d'économistes même Olivier Babou avait
le sourire sans creuser la dette sans
impôts nouveau ça semble compliqué on le
fait évidemment c'est-à-dire que les 54
milliards du plan France 2030 ils sont
conditionnés et si Arcelor fait qu'une
partie du boulot et arrête ces
investissements il y a une clause dans
les accords ce qu'on appelle de clobacs
on reprendra les subventions ça
n'existait pas avant donc
l'investissement comment
on a vu tout à l'heure donc il y en a
une partie qui va venir de l'État
effectivement et pour ça il faut être
économie ailleurs moi je fais pas partie
des gens qui pensent que l'impôt soit un
gros mot c'est un truc c'est comme on
impose plus que nulle part ailleurs dans
le monde je pense qu'on impose déjà
beaucoup c'est vrai et donc il faut à la
fois assurer
et oui et je suis désolé et du coup
faire un peu de croissance elle sera
meilleur elle sera économe encore bonne
mais c'est vrai que si en plus on
rajoute la décroissance de l'impôt et de
la dette là on va avoir un autre
borne sur justement le chiffrage de la
planification qui a été reportée 17
juillet merci à vous on s'arrête là
merci d'être venu débattre monsieur le
ministre et mes deux invités sur LCP
vous restez avec moi Olivier Babou dans
une dizaine de minutes les parties pris
de nos affranchis ce soir le duo du
vendredi d'Harry grand Perrier avec le
mot de la semaine de mariage d'Harry
Grancey apaisement et puis un cri
d'alarme de mettre Perrier ce soir face
à la pénurie de recrutement dans
l'éducation nationale enfin de Bourbon
express et les amende un Gava de quoi
parle-t-on Myriam je vous parle minute
de silence à l'Assemblée elle fondait
pas puisqu'il apparemment bah tout fait
débat merci on a hâte de vous entendre
on se plonge d'abord dans votre livre la
tyrannie du divertissement Olivier
Gbagbo vous avez bien choisi votre maman
la crise des retraites et puisqu'elle a
révélé pour nous dire et bien que le
temps libre attention il faut savoir
l'utiliser on est dévoré par nos écrans
et il y a dans ce temps libre quelque
chose à reconstruire pour donner du sens
on voit ça dans l'invitation de Pierre
Miquel Carmiel on en parle ensemble
juste après
si on vous invite Olivier babot c'est
parce que pendant les débats sur la
réforme des retraites on a beaucoup
parlé du temps de travail et donc
logiquement du temps libre pendant
lequel on se divertit dans votre dernier
ouvrage vous dénoncez la tyrannie du
divertissement une perte de temps à vous
entendre
économiste vous êtes aussi rédacteur
pour des journaux plutôt de droite comme
le Figaro ou franc tireur à la tête de
l'Institut sapiens vous étudiez la place
de l'homme dans la société numérique une
thématique que vous connaissez bien vous
y avez déjà consacré plusieurs ouvrages
comme les luttes sociales les évolutions
technologiques ont permis de réduire
comme jamais le temps de travail passant
de 4000 heures par an avant le XIXe
siècle à 1400 heures de travail
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui on a beaucoup
plus de temps qu'avant je ne le regrette
pas du tout contrairement félicite mais
en réalité c'est un défi considérable il
faut encore plus d'efforts pour réussir
ses loisirs qu'il n'en faut sans doute
pour réussir son travail
une bonne chose selon vous pourtant vous
décrivez deux catégories bien distinctes
à vous lire il y aurait d'un côté les
loisirs studieux dans lesquels nous
sommes actifs et qui nous permettent de
nous accomplir et de l'autre des
divertissements populaires qui ne nous
stimulent pas et nous appauvrissent
l'exemple type passé des heures sur le
canapé à enchaîner des épisodes sur
Netflix vous dites que notre cerveau est
calibré pour la facilité en vous
appuyant sur les neurosciences vous
expliquer que nous sommes comme aspirés
par les écrans il nous paralyse et nous
pousse à la passivité mais ce phénomène
n'est pas nouveau il y a 20 ans le
patron de TF1 en était déjà conscient
pour qu'un message publicitaire soit
perçu il faut que le cerveau du
téléspectateur soit disponible nos
émissions ont pour vocation de le rendre
disponible c'est-à-dire de le divertir
de le détendre pour le préparer entre
deux messages ce que nous vendons un
Coca-Cola c'est du temps de cerveau
humain disponible la tyrannie du
divertissement est donc un appel à la
prise de conscience individuelle nous
avons donc une question pour vous
Olivier babot comment vous vous occupez
votre temps libre
réponse c'est marrant parce que c'est la
première fois qu'on me pose la question
que je parle du livre je sais que vous
allez sortir en juin on s'est dit tiens
qu'est-ce qu'on pourrait lui demander
qu'elle n'a pas répondu il se trouve que
je fais beaucoup de musique parce que je
suis musicien amateur et quand j'étais
étudiant je gagnais ma vie en jouant au
mariage et aux enterrements parce que je
suis organiste et donc aujourd'hui je
fais dès que j'ai un peu de temps je
fais au moins une heure de piano de
clavier par jour joue un peu de lui vous
avez quand même plongé dans dans le
catalogue abyssal de Netflix ça vous est
arrivé bien sûr j'ai été abonné mais je
le suis plus et je regarde de temps en
temps l'une de ces plateformes et en
fait j'ai beaucoup de mal à trouver des
trucs qui m'intéressent je sais pas si
c'est parce que je suis en dépression
mais plus rien ne m'intéresse plus rien
de je ne regarde en fait pour tout vous
dire que des documentaires d'Arte ou
dans un temps effectivement
voilà c'est ça qui m'intéresse en
général ce livre doit tout ou presque à
votre père alors parlez-nous un peu de
lui vous écrivez que vous avez mis du
temps à comprendre quand vous répétant
prend un livre
Ellie et c'est peut-être pas une
contrainte en fait c'était une éthique
de vie qu'il vous proposait en fait le
mon père est doublement l'origine de ce
livre puisqu'en effet c'était quelque
chose qui m'énervait quand j'étais petit
prends un livre et lit chaque fois que
je venais dire comme tous les enfants
vous savez je m'ennuie aujourd'hui c'est
mes enfants qui viennent me voir en me
disant je m'ennuie je leur dis prends un
livre Élie je sais que sur le moment il
me croit pas et qu'un jour il
reconnaîtront que j'avais raison et la
deuxième raison qui fait que c'est mon
père qui est à l'origine c'est que à
l'origine de ce livre en fait il y a le
décès de mon père quasiment en train de
travailler puisqu'il était professeur
d'université professeur spécialiste
d'économie spécialiste de l'épargne et
du patrimoine et il avait envoyé son
dernier article un journal économique
juste avant de mourir et en fait ça m'a
aidé
que la question du temps libre vous
observe toujours la différence entre
travail et loisirs mais quand on a un
métier qui est aussi une profession
comme c'est le cas des musiciens
peut-être des intellectuels aussi c'est
leur mode de vie en fait qui est leur
métier et donc on va pas distinguer
activité rémunéré activité par rémunéré
beaucoup plus intéressant et de
distinguer activité qui émancipe
activité qui qui alien et ben
malheureusement il y a du loisir qui
alien aussi alors ce qui est très
intéressant dans ce livre c'est
l'histoire que vous retracez du rapport
de l'homme au travail vous allez vous
rappeler les grandes étapes rapidement
le temps pour soi finalement c'est très
très récent dans notre histoire ça on
est en train de refermer une parenthèse
de 10 000 ans il y a 10 000 ans vous
savez c'est le néolithique c'est-à-dire
la sédentarisation avant on était nomade
et on travaillait c'était la semaine des
deux jours on travaillait entre trois
quatre heures par jour grand maximum en
fait on ne faisait pas grand chose du
temps du Paléolithique à partir du
Néolithique et bien apparaît la
propriété les différences sociales les
inégalités des formes d'exploitation
c'est tout à fait vrai et puis en fait
le travail et on a commencé à travailler
on a touché le fond de la piscine au 19e
siècle effectivement 70% d'une vie au
19e siècle une vie éveillée c'était du
travail on fait pas très longtemps on
continue à vivre pas très longtemps vos
souvenirs quand on a mis la retraite à
65 ans 1945 les ouvriers l'espérance de
vie elles étaient plutôt entre 55 et 60
on était censé être mort en moyenne vous
voyez complètement de croître ce temps
libre aujourd'hui il y a une grande
bascule avec la révolution industrielle
12%
de notre temps éveillé seulement si vous
êtes aujourd'hui 85 ans votre temps
éveillé à travailler ça sera seulement
12% on n'a jamais si peu travaillé mais
il faut s'en réjouir non complètement
d'autant plus que en fait on a accès à
des lois enfin des loisirs à une qualité
de vie en fait qui est extraordinaire
qu'on avait pas autrefois en travaillant
beaucoup plus elle a vraie question
c'est que maintenant que fait-on de tout
ce temps parce que on a pensé qu'il y
avait une corrélation entre temps libre
et bonheur on se voit que c'est pas tout
à fait vrai malheureusement on peut se
sentir assez mal le temps libre ne
répond pas aux problèmes de l'absence de
sens d'une vie au vide téléologique on
pourrait dire il y a un piège avec ce
temps libre c'est qu'il a cédé la place
aux divertissement qui ne construit rien
qui nous vide qui nous gâche la vie Tik
Tok Instagram les réseaux sociaux il y a
rien de bon là-dedans pour vous si alors
c'est compliqué c'est que je fais les
idéototypes c'est le temps pour les
autres le temps hors de soi et le temps
pour soi c'est hors de soi voilà le
temps
je fais allusion évidemment
divertissement de Pascal c'est alors
pour Pascal c'est tout ce qui t'éloigne
de Dieu mais alors moi dans mon
exception c'est de dire tout ce qui
t'éloigne de toi-même tout ce qui te
fait oublier à toi-même qui t'a moins de
riz là où tu es passif et en fait les
spécialistes de neurologie explique
pourquoi tu ça fait 45 minutes sans t'en
apercevoir sur les réseaux sociaux c'est
parce qu'en fait ton cerveau repère que
c'est pas important ce que tu es en
train de faire et que tu sautes d'un
sujet à un autre avec un temps
d'attention qui est extrêmement court ce
qui est une autre caractéristique
aujourd'hui on a moins de mémoire et on
atteint l'intention de plus en plus
court le fameux poisson rouge de Bruno
Patino et en fait on se rend compte que
ces médias c'est leur modèle économique
de capter notre attention pour y être le
plus longtemps mais malheureusement leur
modèle économique c'est pas tellement
qu'on soit heureux ou qu'on se sente
mieux et d'ailleurs il y a une explosion
des épisodes dépressifs majeurs aux
États-Unis depuis la généralisation du
portable à partir de 2012 environ c'est
extrêmement frappant ce qui est
intéressant aussi dans cette tyrannie
c'est qu'elle est source d'inégalité ça
c'est très important on n'utilise pas le
temps libre de la même façon alors c'est
vrai que c'est souvent une question
d'argent elle est voyager ça coûte de
l'argent mais pas seulement d'ailleurs
les gens qui réussissent le mieux et
d'ailleurs qui vivent le plus longtemps
alors c'est c'est les ceux qui vivent
longtemps pardon c'est les enseignants
et ceux qui réussissent le mieux c'est
les fils d'enseignants statistiquement
en fait et donc ce sont des gens à qui
on a transmis une sorte de discipline de
la façon dont vous allez occuper votre
loisir et donc l'un de mes de mes thèses
c'est que malheureusement cette
explosion du temps de loisir elle
multiplie les inégalités ou en tout cas
elle est un levier de transmission
d'inégalité extrêmement pernicieux parce
qu'on le voit pas vraiment en fait on
parle très peu social plus vous
augmentez le temps d'écran vous doublez
en fait les plaisirs de qualité parce
que vous faites la distinction entre ce
temps pour rien ces réseaux sociaux qui
nous rendent complètement vide un peu
apathique et puis les loisirs qui vous
transportent transforment est-ce que
vous êtes pas un tout petit peu dans un
élitisme un peu aveugle que de croire
que les arts vous pratiquez la musique
la lecture c'est vraiment à la portée de
tous alors en fait moi dans les loisirs
studieux ce que j'appelle la scolaire
par allusion homogrecque je mets pas
seulement que que les beaux-arts ou que
la musique en fait c'est tous les
moments où on est actif par exemple si
on a sa propre chaîne TikTok et qu'on
crée des des chorégraphies qu'on fait
des émissions et ben en fait on est dans
la scolaire en fait on est vraiment dans
ce loisir studio c'est très vaste studio
c'est aussi le sport la culture de
vous-même de ce que vous êtes tout ce
qui est de la méditation la discussion
avec des amis d'ailleurs parce que là
aussi c'est du loisir avec les autres
vous enrichissez vous vous connaissez
mieux peut-être aussi vous vous apaisez
et je pense que c'est ça qui conduit au
bonheur c'est pas si exigeant en réalité
la libido la volonté de savoir plaisir
de la connaissance le goût de l'effort
personnel comment on le retrouve comment
on transmet est-ce que c'est l'école
est-ce qu'on attend pas un peu trop
justement de se cadre éducatif sans
doute l'école devait le faire mais vous
savez que pour un enfant pour chaque
heure d'école il y a au moins une heure
d'écran en moyenne beaucoup plus en fait
donc en fait la majeure partie du
développement de l'enfant il se fait
dans le reste dans tout le reste l'école
elle fait ce qu'elle peut elle est là
vous savez comme disait Montaigne
éduquer c'est pas remplir un vase c'est
la lumière un feu bien avant Johnny on
allumait le feu et l'idée c'est que
cette école elle est là pour donner
envie d'ABS non seulement transmettre
des savoirs mais donner cette envie
d'apprendre toute la vie et elle devrait
rappeler tous les jours vous savez
l'école c'est ce que faisait les gens
les plus riches autrefois c'était une
poignée d'élite qui avait accès à ce
qu'on faisait quand on était assez riche
pour pas travailler c'est un une chance
extraordinaire dont les enfants
bénéficient ça devrait les suivre toute
la vie et l'idée de trouver plus de sens
dans les loisirs que dans le travail
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez on le sent
bien c'est pas toute la population mais
il y a une partie de la jeunesse qui
considère qu'au fond la préférence pour
les loisirs doit être un une forme de
critères dans la carrière est-ce qu'il
faut sont désolés absolument j'ai
l'impression qu'aujourd'hui il y a une
recherche de chance de chance pardon
dans le travail comme dans le loisir
avoir abandonné le travail ne donne pas
du sens aux loisirs on peut y trouver
des choses dans du bénévolat par exemple
ou dans plein d'activités qui vous font
vous réaliser tant que le plus important
c'est ce que disait à mes professeurs en
Sorbonne il me disait c'est l'impression
de philosophie il nous disait il faut
que vous trouviez ce qui dans la vie et
votre genre de beauté c'est à dire ce
qui vous allume ce qui vous vous rend
passionné on me demande parfois tiens
est-ce que les jeunes sont paresseux
aujourd'hui mais absolument pas il y a
aucune raison qui le soit plus
aujourd'hui qu'hier non en revanche
peut-être qu'on a plus de mal à trouver
ce qui vous passionne ce qui vous allume
une fois que vous êtes allumé passionné
par quelque chose il y a rien qui peut
vous résister le goût de l'effort cette
valeur du travail
fait quand on est un homme politique
pour c'est quoi c'est du discours ou
c'est des actions politiques concrètes
est-ce que il y a les moyens de changer
ça au niveau d'une société quand on
quand on est acteur public intéressant
c'est qu'autrefois la gauche avait une
grande conscience de la nécessité d'une
politique culturelle au moment du Front
populaire l'idée de la semaine de
vacances c'était pas tellement pour
aller sur les plages c'était considéré
un loisir bourgeois c'était pour avoir
du temps en 1848 le premier projet de
loi qui n'a pas été voté finalement mais
qui était les attendus de la loi c'était
de dire il faut que les gens se reposent
pour limiter le temps de travail pour la
première fois on limite de son travail
848 il faut que les gens se reposent
mais il faut qu'il se cultive et
regarder quand François mitter en 1980
est arrivé et ça a tenu trois ans
seulement mais le ministère du temps
libre et bien c'est marrant parce
qu'aujourd'hui quelque part et ça
libéral qui vous dit ça on a laissé le
temps libre au marché on l'a abandonné à
des plateformes
il y a plus de politique du temps libre
politique culturel elle est assez
différente
c'est comp
merci beaucoup Olivier Babeau la
tyrannie du divertissement ne laissez
pas les loisirs gâchez votre vie et
celle de vos enfants c'est-à-dire chez
bucher Chastel merci à vous vous restez
avec moi c'est l'heure de nos affranchis
vous allez pouvoir réagir à leur part et
prix on les accueille tout de suite
le duo je le disais du vendredi Perrier
d'Harry grand qu'on apprécie forcément
tout sourire mettre Bertrand Perrier la
sémiologue Mariette darrigran c'est à
vous dans un instant mais on commence
comme chaque soif par Bourbon Express
histoire de jouer à l'Assemblée nous est
racontée par Elsa mon dingava ce soir
bon soirée bonsoir je vais vous parler
de l'histoire des minutes de silence à
l'Assemblée nationale elle fond des
bases je vous donne un exemple c'était
il y a trois semaines lors de la séance
de questions gouvernement après un
terrible naufrage d'une embarcation au
large de la Grèce le député Emeric Caron
se lève et voilà ce qui se passe en leur
mémoire je vous propose chers collègues
mesdames et messieurs les ministres que
nous observions une minute de silence
super collègues je trouve que
effectivement vous cette idée est
formidable mais la Conférence des
Présidents est là pour ça pour que nous
puissions décider collectivement des
moments dans lesquels dans cette
émission nous honorons les personnes
disparues on ne fait pas de minutes de
silence de cette façon là c'est
extrêmement surpris qu'elle bloque la
minute de silence c'est pour moi ça
semblait insensé d'autant plus que
lorsqu'on regarde les images on
s'aperçoit que très spontanément
beaucoup de députés se lèvent mais même
des membres du gouvernement puisque la
première ministre se lève il y a pas de
polémique puisque d'ailleurs ce n'était
absolument pas fait pour déclencher une
polémique on doit pouvoir continuer à
être libre à proposer un moment de
recueillement qui semble s'imposer par
le simple bon sens la simple humanité et
si quelques députés sont dérangés bien à
ce moment-là ils peuvent rester assis ça
les regarde ils seront en paix avec leur
conscience ou pas peu importe
ce que reproche Emery Caron c'est en
fait une sorte de flou à l'Assemblée
nationale sur les minutes de silence
c'est vrai qu'il y a rien dans le
règlement pour fixer un cadre et on voit
qu'il y a des cas de figure très
différents par exemple la semaine
dernière il y en a une des idées
collectivement en conférence des
présidents c'était pour honorer la
mémoire de Léon Gautier le dernier
survivant du commando Kieffer je vous
demande de bien vouloir observer une
minute de silence
alors celle-ci fait l'unanimité et puis
il y en a d'autres qui sont à
l'initiative de la présidente seule je
vous invite à respecter une minute de
silence en mémoire de Naël en soutien à
ses parents et à ses proches
pour celle-ci en revanche Marine Le Pen
la présidente du groupe du Rassemblement
national avait appelé un peu plus de
mesures il y a encore d'autres cas de
figure c'est cette plus spontanée à la
demande des députés c'était le 4
Sandrine Roussan en novembre dernier qui
demande une minute de silence après le
meurtre d'un agent des impôts et là
cette fois la présidente dit ok nous
demandons de respecter une minute de
silence
on demande une minute de silence madame
la Présidente
j'ai bien entendu madame Rousseau et
effectivement après cet acte absolument
tragique je pense qu'effectivement
l'Assemblée nationale peut s'associer à
la douleur de la famille et au respect
que nous devons à tous ces serviteurs de
l'État qui agissent au quotidien pour
notre pays
très clairement que ces minutes de
silence font débat mais ça n'est pas
nouveau non rappelez-vous c'était en
novembre 2014 Cécile Duflot qui après
avoir été ministre était redevenu député
elle elle demandait un moment de
recueillement après la mort de Rémi
Fraisse le militant écologiste tué à
saint-sivain le groupe écologiste
souhaite donc consacrer une minute de
cette question
à une minute de silence pour dire
combien nous sommes touchés par la mort
de ce jeune manifestant qui ne faisait
que défendre la nature
madame Duflot il est de tradition dans
notre hémicycle de saluer par une minute
de silence les décès survenues parmi nos
forces armées ou parmi les otages donc
je vous demande de poursuivre votre
question
voilà on voit bien que ça fait des bas
et que ça ne date pas d'hier pourtant la
présidente elle boit une pivée a voulu
préciser les règles oui justement comme
ça faisait des bas regardez le document
qu'elle a transmis au groupe politique
de l'assemblée il est stipulé que sauf
exception le respect d'une minute de
silence doit résulter soit d'une
initiative de la présidente de
l'Assemblée nationale soit d'une
décision de la Conférence des Présidents
il est inscrit que cette méthode permet
de s'assurer d'un consensus parmi les
groupes et de garantir que la minute de
silence se déroule avec toute la dignité
requise reste à savoir s'il y a beaucoup
de sujets qui font encore consensus dans
cette question c'est compliqué ces
sujets je sais pas qui écrit après une
musique de Mozart même le silence et de
Mozart et ben le silence à l'Assemblée
il est aussi politique c'est ça qui est
fait et voilà tout est politique à
l'Assemblée nationale est
particulièrement particulièrement dans
cette nouvelle Assemblée Bertrand
l'avocat que vous êtes avait envie de
revenir en cette fin d'année scolaire
sur les difficultés de recrutement dans
l'éducation nationale j'ai vu les
chiffres c'est désolant ils ont été
publiés hier le ministère a publié
constitué de la campagne de recrutement
2023 des enseignants et c'est très
inquiétant en effet parce que beaucoup
manquent à l'appel dans le primaire il y
a 1500 postes qui n'ont pas été pourvu
par les concours classiques et donc il
faut aller chercher les listes
complémentaires les concours
supplémentaires les professionnels qui
sont en reconversion et les contractuels
dont on sait que c'est une population
fragile et c'est la même chose au
collège et au lycée puisque là encore
près de 20% des postes offerts au
concours n'ont pas été pourvu notamment
dans des matières essentielles les
lettres classiques et modernes les
mathématiques les sciences physiques on
sait que le Président de la République
avait promis pas un professeur à moins
de 2000 euros net par mois et bien il y
a encore loin de la coupe aux lèvres et
l'attractivité de la profession reste
encore trop faible pour les étudiants la
crainte c'est évidemment un recrutement
au rabais oui et la Cour des comptes
elle-même avait tiré la sonnette
d'alarme en février dernier et c'est
vrai que quand on voit des taux de
réussite au concours de
84% au CAPES de l'aide classique de 56%
au CAPES de mathématiques on ne peut pas
s'empêcher d'avoir un doute or c'est
essentiel c'est un sujet majeur on peut
ensuite faire tous les discours qu'on
veut sur l'égalité des chances sur la
lutte contre les déterminismes sociaux
sur l'avenir qu'on doit nos enfants en
fait tout est dans la dépendance de ces
professeurs que l'on met ou qu'on ne met
pas en face de si on n'est pas capable
de mettre dans chaque classe un
professeur compétent et motivé et bien
encore une fois ces discours seront
creux vides voire mensonger c'est une
supercherie de dire qu'il y a une
égalité des chances s'il n'y a pas une
égalité face à l'enseignement qui est le
premier droit et derrière qu'est-ce qui
se passera et bien les gens voteront
avec leurs pieds ils iront dans le privé
qui tirera les marrons du feu et ce sera
le signe de la faillite du pacte
républicain alors vous voulez quand même
terminer sur une petite note attentive
il y a beaucoup d'enseignants qui
restent mobilisés pour la réussite de
leurs élèves on l'avait la Sorbonne oui
alors évidemment il y a l'impression
d'une école un peu à deux vitesses on
voit les enseignants qui sont reprises
avec des élèves difficiles de
comportements de savoir et puis hier il
y a eu cette petit moment presque un peu
hors-sol très cette pièce de musée à la
Sorbonne qui était à la remise des prix
du concours général alors ça existe
depuis le 18e siècle et depuis il y a eu
des récipients d'air évidemment très
prestigieux Alain Juppé tant d'autres et
cette année encore 20 000 privilégiés
privilégiés par leur travail et leur
mérite on concouru sur la base du
volontariat à ce concours général qui
prime dans toutes les disciplines y
compris professionnelles et
technologiques les lycéens les plus
travailleurs les plus doués les plus
motivés et c'est magnifique c'est
magnifique je trouve parce que ça dit
aussi que il y a une beauté dans le défi
de l'excellence dans Paris tout à
l'heure le goût de l'effort le
dépassement de soi la rigueur la soif
d'apprendre pour s'élisser un là
encadrer et motiver par quelques
hussards noirs qui restent encore les
fers de lance de cette exigence et bien
ces jeunes gens là ont de cette soif
d'apprendre une ambition un désir de
réussite une passion un épanouissement
et je voulais leur dire mon admiration
ils sont 150 à avoir été le ré en
réalité 148 parce qu'il y en a même qui
ont deux prix et
je n'y étais pas on a l'impression
que je veux leur dire à quel point ils
ont mon admiration c'est une belle
jeunesse c'est aussi un contraste avec
l'image que l'on donne parfois de la
jeunesse et pour terminer je voudrais
vous donner à tous et peut-être surtout
vous à Mariette le sujet du concours de
philosophie sur lequel ils ont planché
encore une fois ils ne sont forcés à
rien ils ne peuvent ne pas venir mais
ils le font pas goût de l'effort et du
geste le sujet magnifique du concours
général de philosophie était le choix
des mots un sujet évidemment pour vous
Mariette et pour nous tous merci ça fait
du bien des
parties malgré malgré cette pénurie de
recrutement
je vois des mots via le choc des photos
aussi qui était possible
ça me faisait penser à Paris Match
pour être présenté au concours général
au lycée
on termine avec vous Mariette vous
vouliez nous parler de ce mot c'est
votre mot de la semaine apaisement oui
pour une fois qu'on a un mot positif
mais rien mais il faut le saisir
apaisement on n'a pas beaucoup parlé de
colère dans la crise il faut le
remarquer beaucoup de gens ont parlé
d'apaisement les gens de la rue mais
notre président aussi qui avait parlé
des 100 jours pour apaiser la France et
puis on entend parler à propos de
l'Ukraine etc donc alors là c'est pas
l'apaisement comme on aura dans quelques
semaines avec les piqûres de moustiques
on se met un peu d'huile essentielle
pour calmer non il faut entendre le mot
fondamental le mot paix voilà c'est
cette apaisement là autour de la paix
qui nous que je voudrais souligner
aujourd'hui parce que je crois qu'il
nous indique trois choses d'abord il
nous indique la gravité de la situation
nous avons une espèce de conscience
collective que le contraire de la PC la
guerre et que peut-être la guerre civile
nous menace deuxième chose c'était
intéressant dans cette crise c'est à mon
avis une différence par rapport à 2005
c'est à dire qu'il y a des gens à
l'intérieur des quartiers comme on dit
qui était pour l'apaisement qui l'ont
fait savoir les maires de famille par
exemple et ça sera il y aura des
conséquences et troisième chose c'est
peut-être plus surprenant il y a un lien
Myriam entre la paix et l'argent le fait
de payer et d'apaiser ah oui alors
dites-nous la ppai X et la ppie se
ressemblent c'est le moment en fait
parce qu'il y a le remonte au même verbe
latin pas carré et alors c'est l'idée
intéressante c'est-à-dire que parfois
dans un conflit et bien l'argent est une
un médiateur intéressant on calme le jeu
par un deal donc si tu veux la paix
prépare le deal ce serait assez
intéressant mais on voit bien que là en
l'occurrence avec notre crise des
banlieues et bien on n'a pas le bon deal
parce qu'on ne sait pas est-ce qu'on a
mis trop d'argent et c'est le pognon
dingue pour pas grand chose ou est-ce
qu'au contraire c'est le cash misère
même pas 1% du budget de l'État on ne
sait pas à quel dit il se vouer je
trouve en ce moment en tout cas la
facture est élevée voilà c'est sûr pour
reconstruire exactement ça on le sait
les dégâts matériel sont immenses alors
devant ça devant ces scènes de pillages
de nos pillage aussi et j'ai un peu
hésité parce qu'il a été beaucoup
employé je crois qu'il faut repenser
justement en plus que jamais à cette
paix fondamentale parce que c'est quoi
le politique c'est ça que ça nous
rappelle on est à l'os là la politique
c'est la paix contre la guerre c'est
vraiment ça il y a pas 3e voie c'est
l'un ou l'autre c'est une dichotomie
ancienne primaire notre démocratie elle
est née au 14e siècle dans les communes
toscanes il y a le mur de l'appel le
build de la guerre à Sienne c'est à ça
que nous revenons c'est vraiment
fondamental alors notre président pour
finir il a bien raison de parler
d'apaisement mais il faut qu'il emploie
le mot sens fondamental c'est pas calmer
le jeu là en l'occurrence et puis on
passe à autre chose le politique là il
doit c'est très lourd mais il doit
refonder le pacte républicain comme on
dit c'est-à-dire que c'est vraiment le
droit de vivre dans une société de paix
donc certains vont avoir un été je pense
très occupé c'est peut-être pour ça
qu'il prend son temps le président avant
de parler et on attend voilà ce qu'il
dira le 14 juillet c'est vrai qu'à
sienne d'ailleurs on l'appelle aussi la
fresque du bon et du mauvais
gouvernement exactement là les deux noms
c'est la fresque du bon et du mauvais
gouvernement la paix et la guerre merci
à vous merci Mariette Bertrand Elsa
Merci à VOUS Olivier babot la tyrannie
du divertissement c'est-à-dire chez
buché Chastel c'est le weekend profitez
bien et à la semaine prochaine
[Musique]